this is Jocko podcast number 78 with
echo Charles and me Jocko willing
good evening echo good evening nightmare
now that's a word that I use often times
to describe the most horrible things or
the most wretched things and in my
hierarchy of adjectives nightmare is
right alongside of Hell I'm not sure
which one is worse in my mind that's why
I say they're right alongside each other
because hell is beyond the worst thing
your mind can imagine and that's
basically what a nightmare is when
you're asleep and your mind delves into
the most horrific things beyond what you
can consciously and wilfully imagine in
your own head that's what a nightmare is
now what if there was a place that was
worse than a nightmare and it was a real
place who could create such a place and
the answer to that is we can
I shall never forget how I was roused
one night by the groans of a fellow
prisoner who threw himself about in his
sleep obviously having a horrible
nightmare since I had always been
especially sorry for people who suffer
from fearful dreams or deliria I wanted
to wake the poor man suddenly I drew
back the hand which was ready to shake
him frightened at the thing I was about
to do at that moment I became intensest
intensely conscious of the fact that no
dream no matter how horrible could be as
bad as the reality of the camp which
surrounded us and to which I was about
to recall him and that's a quote from
the book man's search for meaning by
Viktor Frankl which will be appearing in
two today and it's a book about the Nazi
concentration camps which are really as
he pointed out they're worse than any
nightmare we can imagine here's a
holocaust survivor
eddie weinstein on the death and the
atrocities in Treblinka by now the
transports were coming every day one was
much like the next the same incidence
recurred again and again once as I swept
out the interior of a car an SS man
suddenly struck me with his whip and
ordered me to help a woman who was
unable to stand and climb out of the car
the idea was to show his victims how
well the ill were being treated then he
ordered one of the workers to take the
women take the woman through the field
the field hospital for care the
newcomers really believed that the alien
woman would
be taken to an infirmary none of them
realized that the field hospital was in
fact just a giant pit about 30 yards in
diameter which was always ablaze they
would place those who were sick or
disabled on the ground at the edge of
the pit facing in the SS man and the
in-charge circulated among them and shot
them in the back of the neck then the
workers cast them into the pit some of
the victims were still breathing when
they were tossed in with the other
bodies the pit was separated from the
spacious field by a barrier of fresh
pine branches which will replace from
time to time to conceal the infirmary
from the newcomers until the last moment
20 minutes after I helped the woman
climb out of the railroad car I was told
that some infants were sitting by the
pit and no one else was there because
the SS soldier had taken his lunch break
I gathered some trash and went over
there I saw the woman who I had removed
from the car still breathing sitting at
the edge of the pit and staring and
fright into the burning Inferno and its
contents the half cremated bodies of old
people and children mixed with
smoldering trash she tried to stand up
but her legs would not hold her she
looked at the workers who stirred the
embers remnants of human beings so they
would burn better nearby were about a
dozen infants too young to have learned
how to walk they were not crying they
certainly did not understand what was
happening they looked about almost
certainly in hopes of finding their
mother or father later I heard that
right after he returned from his lunch
break the SS man shot them all and
ordered the workers to throw the tiny
bodies into the flames of all my
memories of that accursed place the
vision of these babies is undoubtedly
the worst
I see their faces whenever I remember
Treblinka as I write these lines more
than 50 years after that day I still
cannot overcome the horror in another
report here Martin's pet of tar now
Poland describes the massacre of torn
out Jews in an interview
we heard the columns of Jews under
German escort at night it was going
constantly they were passing our house
because this was already on the
outskirts of the city the cemetery and
they were marching them to the woods
behind the city as we found out later
they were all shot over there during the
day I looked out through the shingles my
father said I shouldn't look but anyway
I was a kid I was curious and the roof
was overlooking a cemetery and wagons
with bodies dead bodies were coming in
groups they were bringing in groups of
Jewish people that had to dig trenches
they had to dig ditches and the bodies
dumped in and after those Jews that dug
the ditches they were shot also and
pushed in by another group that came in
after them into those ditches and lime
was poured over the bodies and the next
group covered up those ditches and dug
other ditches
they brought in pregnant women and they
didn't use any bullets
they used bayonets the screams of the
mothers that their children they tore
their children out of their arms and the
screams of the children I still hear
and Solomon radowski who is the only
survivor from the 78 people in his
family described the concentration camp
they throw the people in the
crematoriums the children I will never
forget alive they throw them in the
crematoriums they grabbed by an arm by a
leg by the head and throw them into the
ovens there it was so tragic the cries
and people when crying there you know it
was so terrible I can feel it now I can
even see the people the other people
were crying the children were hollering
mama
daddy help me mama daddy help me it was
terrible
and one more report on Treblinka from
Henry gold and the worst thing that
happens to a person in that instance he
loses self-respect and that's exactly
what happened to the majority of the
people some of them even lost their
minds they couldn't take it they
couldn't take the hunger they couldn't
take the beatings they couldn't take the
cold no clothing and the uncertainty and
the uncertainty I think that was the
worst thing that can happen to a person
you didn't know from one moment to the
next what was going to happen life was
very cheap a person was alive one minute
the next minute he was shot killed
beaten up beaten to death torn apart
apart by dogs and so on life was very
very cheap and that's the way the
Germans liked it
that particular camp was governed by the
Jewish Jewish police and so on the
Germans did not stay in the camp they
were on the outside but the life inside
of the camp was just as bad without the
Germans being right there than if they
would be the Jewish police was I don't
know you take a person in that situation
and you give them a little power and he
becomes the same as the oppressor
himself there were some policemen that
were not bad but there were a lot of
them that were ruthless there were
others that would beat people and do all
kinds of things that would degrade them
and so on
especially women they cut their hair off
and they look like men they look like
scarecrows and they would get beaten up
by the Jewish police just as bad as the
man for no reason at all if they wanted
a little more soup where they were
distributing soup and there was some
left and they were going to give
everybody a little bit and the Jewish
police with their sticks and rubber
hoses would beat them half cents
senseless and that's what happens when
the conditions are the way they were
then when a person becomes an animal and
loses self-respect that is willing to
get a beating and get beaten half
senseless just to get a little bit of
soup either you died or if you didn't
die the Germans would come and take you
away the filth was just terrible in the
camp in the barracks you had cops
I mean bunks where everybody slept on
straw there were no covers was no
pillows nothing you slept in your
clothes in the winters in the winter
because you're afraid to get cold
the only heating was a pot-bellied stove
in the middle of the barrack when
somebody stole some wood in the factory
or something then we had a fire
otherwise it was freezing and the only
warmth they had if you huddled together
and they kept warm that way but nobody
would get undressed the lice were eating
you up alive once a month you allowed to
take a shower and we had to walk to camp
a to go to the showers and that means a
10-mile walk 10 miles there and 10 miles
back a lot of people were too weak to
walk and those people hardly ever took a
shower there was no hot water in the
washroom there was only cold and in the
winter you were afraid to wash up
because there was nothing to wipe
yourself with therefore you would walk
out in the cold winter and freeze to
death
[Music]
and Henry gold brothers and both of his
parents were all killed in the gas
chambers and from the Buchenwald report
which was translated and edited with an
introduction by David a Hackett I will
now describe the crematoriums in the
transports at the station two thousand
people got off the trains they had to
throw away all their luggage afterward
the men and women were divided into two
groups at which the larger boys were
assigned to the group with the men then
that great devourer of Jews Mengele
drove buying a car seeking out the
strongest from each transport they
numbered around thirty out of two
thousand the remainder were led away by
SS technical sergeant mole the officer
of the crematorium the elderly were
loaded onto dump trucks and then dumped
into burning trenches while still alive
the remainder were led to the gas
chambers meanwhile new transports were
arriving in front of the gas chamber was
a dressing room on its walls was written
in all languages put shoes into the
cubbyholes and tie them together so you
will not lose them after the showers you
will receive hot coffee here poor
victims undress themselves and went into
the chamber there were three columns for
the ventilators through which the gas
poured in a special work detail with
dungeons drove the people into the
chamber when the room was full small
children were thrown in through a window
sergeant mole grabbed infants by their
legs and smashed their skulls against
the wall then the gas was led into the
chamber the lungs of the victim slowly
burst
and after three minutes a loud clamoring
could be heard then the chamber was open
and those who still showed signs of life
were beaten to death
the prisoners of the special work
details then cold corpses out took their
rings off and cut their hair which was
gathered up put in sacks and shipped to
factories then they arranged the corpses
in piles of ten each after sergeant mole
had counted them they were taken to the
ovens or if the crematoriums
crematoriums were insufficient thrown
into fire trenches once it happened that
a victim crawled out of a burning trench
he was beaten to death with truncheon
'he's on sergeant mole pull put a naked
woman in the trench and shot her in the
genitals
another time mold found a ring on a
member of the special work detail he
ordered nat naphtha poured over him and
had it lighted he hanged a man by his
hands and shot him until his arms were
torn through then he hanged him up by
the feet and repeated the process once
sergeant mole took a family of six first
and shot the youngest in the presence of
the rest then he shot the older ones and
finally their father and mother
[Music]
and that's the testimony of john de
weiss who was 15 years old at Birkenau
so I think it's safe to say that this is
a situation that is definitely worse
than a nightmare and what possibly can
we take away from that I think the best
thing we can do is try and learn and I
think one of the best places to learn
and take lessons away from the Holocaust
is from the book that I started out with
today called man's search for meaning by
Viktor Frankl let's go to the book
let us take the case of a transport
which was officially announced to
transfer a certain number of prisoners
to another camp but it was fairly safe
to guess that its final destination
would be the gas chambers a selection of
sick or feeble prisoners incapable of
work would be sent to one of the big
central camps which were fitted with gas
chambers and crematoriums the selection
process was the signal for a free fight
among all the prisoners or of group
against group all that mattered was that
one's own name and that of one's friends
were crossed off the list of victims
though everyone knew that for each man
saved another victim had to be found a
definite number of prisoners had to go
with each transport it did not really
matter which since each of them was
nothing but a number on their admission
to the camp all their documents had been
taken from them together with other
possessions each prisoner therefore had
an opportunity to claim a fictitious
name a profession and for various
reasons many did this the authorities
were interested only in the captain's
numbers these numbers were often
tattooed on their skin and also had to
be sewn to a certain spot on their
trousers jacket or coat any guard who
wanted to make a charge against a
prisoner just glanced at his number and
how he dreaded those glances he never
asked for his name to return to the
convoy about the depart there was
neither time nor desire to consider
moral or ethical issues every man was
controlled by one thought only to keep
himself alive for the family waiting for
him at home and to save his friends with
no hesitation therefore he would arrange
for another prisoner another number to
take his place in the transport as I
have already mentioned the process of
selecting Kapos was a negative one
only the most brutal of the prisoners
were chosen for this job
so Kappos or prisoners Jewish prisoners
that got selected to help run the prison
camp and and capo I tried to find the
etymology of where that came from and
the best or the closest or the thing
that made the most sense to me from what
I read was was they had two words
combined together
comrade police then the in German does
got shortened to capital so some of
these and you already heard one of those
earlier testimonies talking about the
Jewish police inside the prisons and how
they were just as bad as in many cases
as the Germans themselves back to the
book but apart from the selection of
Kapos which is undertaken by the SS
there was a sort of self-selecting
process going on the whole time among
all the prisoners on the average only
those prisoners could keep alive who
after years of trekking from Camp to
camp had lost all scruples in their
fight for existence they were prepared
to use every means honest and otherwise
even brutal force theft and betrayal of
friends in order to save themselves will
you have come back by the aid of many
lucky chances or miracles whatever one
may choose to call them we know the best
of us did not return
so there's a dynamic that you don't
think of immediately when you think of
the concentration camps number one you
don't think about the kapos the Jewish
police that are forced into this
situation and then the other thing you
don't think about is this the fact that
the people that were going to survive
we're basically making it very broad say
but but you know from what Viktor Frankl
saying here it was the people that were
willing just to do anything to survive
including betraying their friends and
he's saying straight up we know the best
of us did not return and that is
something that you don't think about and
we probably don't think about it because
we don't want to think about it because
when you start thinking about what would
you do to survive what would you do to
survive what would I do to survive and
that's a question I don't think a lot of
people want to know the answer to and
it's very easy to go through life and
never have to answer that question
talking a little bit now about what life
was like in the camp back to the book
somewhere it is said that man cannot
exist without sleep for more than a
stated number of hours quite wrong I had
been convinced that there were certain
things I just could not do I could not
sleep without this or I could not live
without that or the other the first
night in Auschwitz
we slept in beds which were constructed
in tears on each tear measuring about 6
and 1/2 to 8 feet slept 9 men directly
on the boards 2 blankets would be shared
by each 9 men we could of course lie
only on our sides crowded and huddled
against each other which had some
advantages because the bitter cold
though was forbidden to take shoes up to
the bunks
some people did use them secretly as
pillows in spite of the fact they were
caked with mud
otherwise one's head had to rest on the
crook of an almost dislocated arm and
yet sleep came and brought oblivion and
relief from the pain for a few hours
thought a suicide was entertained by
nearly everyone if only for a brief time
it was born of hopelessness of the
situation the constant danger of death
looming over us daily and hourly and the
closeness of deaths suffered by many of
the others from personal convictions
which we mentioned later I made a firm
promise on my first evening in the camp
that I would not run to the wire this
was a phrase used in camp to describe
the most popular method of suicide
touching the electrical electrically
charged barbed wire fence it was not
entirely difficult for me to make this
decision there was a little point in
committing suicide since for the average
inmate life expectation calculating
objectively and Counting all likely
chances was very poor he could not
without any a shirt he could not with
any assurance expect to be among the
small percentage of men who survived all
the selections the prisoner of Auschwitz
in the first phase of shock did not fear
death even the gas chambers lost their
horrors for him after the first few days
after all they spared him the act of
committing suicide
and Viktor Frankl was a psychiatrist
going into this situation so that's the
that's the view that's the perspective
that he takes throughout this and he's
now been in for a couple days in
Auschwitz and another guy comes in to
talk to him who's another colleague of
his and we're going back to book a
colleague of mine who had arrived in
Auschwitz several weeks previously
smuggle himself into our hut he wanted
to come and comfort us and tell us a few
things he had become so thin that at
first we did not recognize him with a
show of good humor and a devil-may-care
attitude he gave us a few hurried tips
don't be afraid don't fear the
selections dr. M the SS medical chief
has a soft spot for doctors but one
thing I beg of you he continued shave
daily if at all possible even if you
have to use a piece of glass to do it
even if you have to give your last piece
of bread for it you look younger and the
scraping will make your cheeks look
routier if you want to stay alive
there's only one way look fit for work
if you even limp because let us say you
have a small blister on your heel and an
SS man spots this he will wave you aside
and the next day you are sure to be
gassed
now his mind and his thoughts he
describes what he would think about back
to the book my mind still clung to the
image of my wife a thought crossed my
mind I didn't even know if she were
still alive
I knew only one thing which I have
learned well by now love goes very far
beyond the physical person of the
beloved it finds its deepest meaning in
his spiritual being in his inner self
whether or not he is actually present
whether or not he is still alive it all
ceases somehow to be of importance I did
not know whether my life wife was alive
and had no means of finding out during
all my prison life
there was no outgoing or incoming mail
but at that moment it ceased to matter
there was no need for me to know nothing
could touch the strength of my love my
thoughts and the image of my beloved had
I known then that my wife was dead I
think that I still would have given
myself undisturbed by that knowledge to
the contemplation of her image and that
my mental conversation with her would
have been just as vivid and just as
satisfying set me like a seal upon my
heart love is as strong as death
they're continuing on dr. Frankel talks
about images from inside the camp
standing outside we saw sinister clouds
glowing in the West and the whole sky
alive with clouds of ever-changing
shapes and colors from steel blue
blood-red the desolate grey mud huts
provided a sharp contrast while the
puddles on the muddy ground reflected
the glowing sky then after a few minutes
of moving silence one prisoner said to
another how beautiful the world could be
and beyond looking for beauty around
them they were able to find humor and I
have people ask me about this from time
to time about humor in combat situations
and isn't it important and yes it
absolutely is and you'd think in a
concentration camp even humor would go
away but not true back to the book to
discover that there was any semblance of
art in a concentration camp must be
surprise enough for an outsider but he
may be even more astonished to hear that
one could find a sense of humor could
find a sense of humor there as well of
course only the faint trace of one and
then only for a few seconds or minutes
humor was another of the souls weapons
in the fight for self-preservation it is
well known that humor more than anything
else in the human makeup can afford an
aloofness and an ability to rise above
any situation if only for a few seconds
the attempt to develop a sense of humor
and to see things in a humorous light is
some kind of trick I learned while
mastering the art of living yet it is
impossible to practice the art of living
even in a concentration camp although
suffering is omnipresent to draw an
analogy a man's suffering is similar to
the behavior of gas
if a certain quantity of gas is pumped
into an empty chamber it will fill the
chamber completely and evenly no matter
how big the chamber
thus suffering completely fills the
human soul and conscious mind no matter
whether the suffering is great or little
therefore the size of human suffering is
absolutely relative and I think the
point that I took away from that was
that chamber that can be filled up with
suffering fill it up with some humor as
well otherwise that that suffering will
just fill the whole chamber will fill
your whole brain back to the book we
were grateful for the smallest of
mercies we were glad when there was time
to deal aus before going to bed although
in itself this was no pressure pleasure
as it meant standing naked in an
unheated hut where icicles hung from the
ceiling but we were thankful if there
was no air raid alarm during this
operation the lights were not switched
off if we could not do the job properly
we were kept awake half the night
[Music]
so you're at a point in life where
you're grateful for being able to stand
naked and pick the lice off of your
friends before you go to bed so the lice
won't keep you awake at night by chewing
at your body and you know I talked about
how or he talks about how you know it
was the person that was going to survive
had to be ruthless basically and here he
says but it's not for me to pass
judgment on those prisoners who put
their own people above everyone else who
can throw a stone at a man who favors
his friends under circumstances when
sooner or later it is a question of life
or death no man should judge unless he
asks himself in absolute honesty whether
in a similar situation he might not have
done the same
but here he says I mentioned earlier how
everything that was not connected with
the immediate task of keeping oneself
and one closest friends lives lost its
value everything was sacrificed to this
end a man's character became involved to
the point that he was caught in mental
turmoil which threatened all values he
held and threw them into doubt under the
influence of a world which no longer
recognized the value of human life and
human dignity which had robbed the man
of his will and made him an object to be
exterminated having planned however to
make full use of him first to the last
ounce of his physical resources under
this influence the personal ego finally
suffered a loss of values if the man in
the concentration camp did not struggle
against this in a last effort to save
his self-respect
he lost the feeling of being an
individual a being with a mind with
inner freedom and personal value he
thought of himself then as only part of
an enormous mass of people his existence
descended to the level of animal life
the men were herded sometimes to one
place then to another sometimes driven
together than apart like a flock of
sheep without a thought or a will of
their own a small but dangerous pack
watched them from all sides well-versed
in methods of torture and sadism they
drove the herd incessantly backwards and
forwards with shouts kicks and blows and
we the sheep thought of two things only
how to evade the bad dogs and how to get
a little food
he's going to delve into this deeper
this idea of this inner freedom and how
hard you had to fight to maintain that
and how easy it was just to roll in and
become one of the pack one of the herd
back to the book it is very difficult
for an outsider to grasp how very little
value was placed on human life in camp
the camp inmate was hardened but
possibly became more conscious of this
complete disregard of human existence
when a convoy of sick men was arranged
the emaciated bodies of the sick were
thrown on two-wheeled carts which were
drawn by prisoners for many miles often
through snowstorms to the next camp if
one of the sick men had died before the
cart left he was thrown on anyways the
list had to be correct the list was the
only thing that mattered
a man counted only because he had a
prison number one literally became a
number dead or alive that was
unimportant the life of a number was
completely irrelevant what stood behind
that number and that life mattered even
less the fate the history the name of
the man
the camp inmate was frightened of making
decisions and of taking any sort of
initiative whatsoever this was the
result of a strong feeling that fate was
one's master and that one must not try
to influence it in any way but instead
let it take its own course in addition
there was a great apathy which
contributed no small part to the
feelings of the prisoner at times
lighting lightning decisions had to be
made decisions would spell life-or-death
the prisoner would have preferred to let
fate make the choice for him and so some
of the examples that he brings up in the
book on that are they'd get told we need
people to go to a different camp for
rest and they had no idea sometimes it
actually was some kind of rest sometimes
it kind of was some kind of actual
medical facility sometimes it was just
you're going to the gas chambers at
another camp and they had no idea which
one it was and so they got into this
mode of they were just going to
externally just whatever was gonna
happen that was gonna happen and they
wouldn't they go beyond when they're
trying in the beginning to like get me
off that list or I want to be on that
list and they realized that they just
were messing with faith that's they got
into motive I'm just going to let things
happen then whatever happens happens
they got this this feeling of apathy you
can just imagine how that that having no
control externally of what's happening
how that leads number one leads to this
apathy of just I don't care what happens
but number two how that that can then
sneak in and start to get control of
your inner thoughts and your inner
feelings where you just feel like you
don't have control over anything in life
and that's it mm-hmm and here he talks
about apathy some more the prisoners
apathy was also the result of other
factors hunger and lack of sleep
contributed to it as they do in normal
life also
and to the general irritability which
was another characteristic of the
prisoner's mental state the lack of
sleep was partly due to the pestering of
vermin which infested the terribly
overcrowded huts because of the general
lack of hygiene and sanitation the fact
that we had neither nicotine nor
caffeine also contributed to the state
of apathy and irritability besides these
physical causes there were mental ones
in the form of certain complexes the
majority of prisoners suffered from a
kind of inferiority complex
we all had once been or had fancy
ourselves to be somebody now we were
treated like complete non entities the
consciousness of one's inner value is
anchored in higher more spiritual things
that cannot be shaken by camp life but
how many freemen let alone prisoners
possess it without consciously thinking
about it the average prisoner felt
himself utterly degraded this became
obvious when one observed the contrasts
offered by the singular sociological
structure of the camp the more prominent
prisoners the Kappos the cooks the store
keepers and the camp policemen did not
as a rule feel degraded at all like the
majority of prisoners but on the
contrary they felt promoted some even
developed miniature miniature delusions
of grandeur clearly we can all take a
lesson out of that one and that is you
know you get put into a promotion
position or you've got authority over
people don't let that go to your head
yeah I guess that's a natural thing
where they did this that experiment best
in that University whatever and they're
all just random student if one played
the prisoner one group played the guards
and that happened yeah you know like act
it's just an experiment it's not real
life you know and it still happened yeah
and it happened in real life
which i think is even more
in st. to you and more and say yeah hey
huh
but then again how can we sit here and
judge when if you're in that situation
and you need to survive and you need to
do the best to get yours.you to survive
in your family survive and you have an
opportunity Oh are we gonna say nope
nope I'm gonna instead of doing this
where I maybe can do something good in
the long run
nope I'm not going to go across my
values I'm gonna die in three days and
that's it yeah that's a hard decision to
make
yeah I mean it seems easy when you're
sitting in the comfort of your home like
I wouldn't do that or you know and this
is what I would have done or I wouldn't
have done that yeah and you know I I
talk to people about again it's I'm not
going to compare anything to what we're
talking about here but in the military
for instance a lot of times I had to
make decisions to - you know I got to do
something that maybe I didn't fully
agree with but I knew in the long run it
was going to get me something that was
going to be beneficial to my team or to
my platoon or whatever and so you make
those little adjustments and you got to
suck it up and you do something that you
might not want to do but in the long run
it's going to be beneficial yeah I mean
this I don't even know if this is even a
remotely close comparison but what I am
saying is this you take a human being
and you say look you can either step up
and act a different way and be abusive
to these people or you're going to be
dead in three days that's it those are
your choices yeah and it's not that hard
to figure out that a lot of people are
going to step up and say cool I'll abuse
those people because I need to live need
to live yeah my choice is either deaf
yeah and by the way maybe the maybe
that's the best person in that group is
going to say you know what I'm going to
do this and I'm going to step up and
when I abuse these people I'm going to
do a little bit less than someone else
might right and therefore I'm doing the
best I can
yeah I mean these are decisions how do
you even think about these decisions you
know man
and you have to think about you have to
understand you have to understand what
human nature is that there's a survival
point for humans you have us an ending
instinct to survive that very few people
can overcome yeah and I don't even you
know again how do you judge whether it's
right to overcome it or not when is it
right I mean obviously when is it right
we're sitting here it's easy to say hey
don't you know these guys why would you
kill yourself well if you don't do these
things you're basically killing yourself
you don't step up if you don't say okay
I'll work as a capo if you don't do that
you're killing yourself right does that
make it okay yeah yeah brutal it's like
you got to figure out whether or not
you're better off dead in the B even in
the grand scheme of things like these
are these people that they're going to
kind of succumb to these positions or do
all these low things to survive so they
can survive and you don't live on and
all this stuff so it's either that or am
I better off dead overall you know like
that's the decision you got to make tank
who knows what you think especially with
all these conditions yeah you know the
opposite of that is dick winters was
talking about how he had and I don't
know if I talked about it on the podcast
but in it in the book conversations with
dick winters he goes through a big
section where he talks about some of the
guys in his company and he called him
the killers and he actually went on and
said hey you know I don't want to call
them killers because that's going to
give the wrong impression but these guys
were my most aggressive guys they were
my best guys and he's and he said they
didn't make it past you know he said
most of them didn't make it I forget
which which battle but he said most of
them didn't make it past this certain
time because they were so aggressive
they were such good guys they were so
brave that they didn't make it and and
this is sort of the opposite where you
have the people that are brave I guess
no it's the same in that people that are
brave and hold to their values they're
going to die right and and if you think
about somebody that's cowardly in combat
that says oh you know what you know echo
you go first I'm going to sit over here
behind this you know a covered position
I'm gonna live longer and it's a micro
example of what we're talking about here
yeah yeah that's kit and just just given
the book and over tomorrow just like
come off as borderline insulting it's
not full-fledged insulting but you ever
watch the show survivor
III was the first one when it was kind
of a thing yeah and there was a
interesting psychology happening
yeah and that's like I was Rudy Bosch
was on it you know this uh she retired
seal mask you know who you know everyone
kind of knew in the SEAL Teams okay yeah
so inspecting what you're going to say
is that the the people that are not good
human beings are the ones that win a lot
of oil they get far put it that way
because they have this weird mechanism
at the end where the last you know few
people who get voted off they become
this sort of a jury so it's like if you
went through the whole game screwing
people over the jury is going to get you
kind of thing so it's a yeah and who's
just how the Cho just sorted itself out
over time but the first ones didn't have
any jury right I don't I don't know I
did in fact I'm gonna go ahead and say I
I'm almost positive they didn't because
Rudy had his hand on some log and they
had to keep it there for like X and for
one I still and one person you know he
actually like thought of something else
and took his hand off and then he was
out that was it dunker but yeah there's
absolute comparison there there's an
absolute comparison to you know if
you're willing to be a snake ring you
can and you can you can win the game and
I've talked about that too and promotion
people getting promoted and if you're
willing to be a snake you can get
promoted but the thing that I will say
in a work environment is that that snake
might get one promotion they might get
two promotions they're not going to go
the distance and if you hold the line on
doing what's correct then you might miss
that first emotion you might even miss
that second promotion but eventually if
you're on the right path you will get
the recognition and you will win in the
long run you got to be patient though
yeah yeah I mean obviously in your job
it's not life or death you know death
isn't so close that you know one slip-up
you're dead
you're dead you know so that's you know
obviously the dynamic of different in
work in that way but otherwise I think
so and survivor there's also that other
thing that kind of what they talk about
where or what you're just talking about
is if you it's kind of in a matter of
speaking playing it safe where you're
just hiding under the wing right
attacker self to someone or you avoid
any kind of you know risky for sure
duration and so in Survivor you can make
it far like that as well yeah I mean
nowadays everyone knows about those
things like all you backstab there one
or you just hid behind this guy cuz he's
drunk but at the same time just like how
you're saying if you're brave or you're
gonna stick your morals and be honest
with everyone like you'll get voted off
real quick even if you're really good at
you know the challenges so in opening
over don't even like really good leaders
get vote like if someone just is a
dynamically do they get or I think that
me write you a letter too much of it
they're actually much of a threat
everybody all right and actually what
you're talking about going through SEAL
training I would hear it was sliding
here when I went through but I heard it
later this idea of the gray man and I
think we might have actually answered a
question on the podcast about that was
going through training and just being a
gray man meaning just don't stand out
right wrong way or the other
and you'll be good to go and that's
that's uh that's that's a strategy why
in the SEAL Teams is that no it's a
strategy going through buds so if you
see your training the initial skill
training course because the minute you
stand out people start knowing who you
are and now you got instructors looking
at you and the more they watch you the
more they can see whether you're making
some mistakes or if you're not doing
everything right or maybe you're not and
so better just be that guy in the middle
I was the guy in the middle not because
I wanted to do it but because I was not
you know the fastest runner I wasn't the
best swimmer what you don't want to be
is the guy on the tail end right
yeah and it's weird because I put so
many guys not through the basic SEAL
training but through the advanced SEAL
training and the guys that I remember
there's two types of guys that I
remember the guys that were awesome and
the guys that were horrible and the guys
in the middle all the gray guys I know
him when I see him but a lot of times I
don't hundred percent got know their
name whereas some of the pipe hitters
the young piped or some e5 pipe hitter
that was just getting after it I'd
always remember those guys names because
they would take control of everything
and stand out and then the other guys
you remember guys that are totally
jacked up so that idea of being a gray
man it seems like a good policy to have
in the concentration camp look I just
don't want to stand out I don't want to
have a limp I don't want to you know
come across as I just want to fit in and
you're a man unless you're going to go
the distance
right which is and that's a horrible way
of saying I'm going to stand out by
saying hey I can whip these prisoners
into shape right that's going and just
raising your hand and saying I'll be a
capo I'm going to step up and what
you're risking there is we don't know
where this war is going to end that
where he's going to be at the end of
this thing yeah and you know I read some
stories about that
the war did end and they did liberate
these camps and it didn't work out good
for the Capo's so there's there's the
same thing you've had a bit done alright
getting your promotion the first couple
times but eventually it comes around
Camille exactly right yeah you know
Harley Flanagan was talking about Karma
and I don't know how much reality
there's that but there's there's the
reality of you reap what you sow yeah
and if you treat people if you if you
take advantage of your position if you
maneuver and screw people over to get
ahead of them they'll remember that yeah
so remember that yeah then that makes
sense I mean karma lives and it's never
worth it by the way if I have almost
never worth it I mean could you possibly
come up with some scenario where we're
you know I did this to get a promotion
so I could take care of you and everyone
else so you could come up with it yes
but it's very very rare and and my gut
feeling was always like - not worth it
not worth it to do those little
maneuvers in trying better your position
on other people's backs
yeah or screwing someone over and you
got to live with that - I mean unless
you're like a sociopath or something
like that you have to live with that and
man yeah and even at the time it seems
like all I could live with that because
oh you know what well you're actually
you're actually taking a higher road
than me because you're saying you
personally have to live with it Annetta
definitely I'm saying beyond that even
if you're a person that can live with it
you're still going to pay in the long
run even if you hook yourself in the
mirror be like I don't care I got
promoted it's good that's that's okay so
you can live with that that's cool but
guess what there's something else you're
going to that's going to come that
around and that is one of those other
people that you stepped on their back is
going to invent something new at work
and you want to take over the division
and you're going to pay not to mention
the ten people who watched it happen and
you know yeah you're just making enemies
yeah enemies and that's really what
karma is for it I mean karma could be
this mystical thing that personally
watches you and has this judgment system
and I'm real just real life just like if
I walk up to a you know even meaner even
we don't know each other I don't have
any bad or good feelings towards you and
I come and I slap you I created a
deficit now now you're intentionally
basically a shaker yeah so your
intention whether you do it or not
you're what you you're compelled to slap
me back if not more usually more yeah
because you know a lot more so that's
kind of really what it is I mean really
in a small teeny tiny nutshell you know
I go out and start acting mad to
everyone what it they're not going to be
like oh I love you I mean they might
because they might be you know
intellectual or you know they might be
able to think about it but their natural
compulsion would be to be Maddox's that
and and this you know the podcast human
nature talking about human nature and I
always say that war reveals human nature
more clearly than anything else because
it's so much pressure on the people
obviously a concentration camp it's
revealing human nature that's exactly
what we're talking about and it reveals
itself in crystal clarity on a massive
scale in terms of being able to see it
in a concentration camp and you see it
reveal itself on a TV show called
Survivor and you see that reveal itself
in in the work environment and what I'm
saying is from all that what you want to
do is you want to make sure that when
you get put into a position of authority
you don't abuse it that's what I'm
saying yeah you don't want to abuse it
you want to treat people with respect no
matter what and you don't want to step
on people's backs to get ahead because
ultimately it's not going to pay off it
really isn't
you know you're only going to fool like
that leader that you that you fooled
into thinking that you are great guys
it's only gonna last for so long yeah
and eventually you're going to get found
out now all right let's get let's get
back into the book here the experiences
of camp life show that man does have a
choice of action and this is we've
talked about the kapil is easy to talk
about some of the more heroic people and
and some of those actions very briefly
and he says because it's the reason
there's very briefly because there
wasn't a lot of them the experiences of
camp life show that man does have a
choice of action there were enough
examples often of a heroic nature which
proved that apathy could be overcome
irritability irritability suppressed man
can preserve a vestige of spiritual
freedom of independence of mind even in
such terrible conditions of psychic and
physical stress we who lived in
concentration camps can remember the men
who walked through huts comforting
others giving away their last piece of
bread they may have been few in number
but they offer sufficient proof that
everything can be taken from a man but
one thing the last of the human freedoms
to choose ones attitude in any given set
of circumstances to choose one's own way
and there it is I mean that is it that
is it this idea and you know captain
plumb talked about it as well and
captain plumb had a cold from Stockdale
and we got to explore this and I've got
a bunch of Stockdale books and I we will
get to some Stockdale books who was the
senior guy in the Hanoi Hilton and he's
a fighter pilot philosopher guy
brilliant guy in a hero won but was
awarded the Medal of Honor
and one of the things that captain palm
was talking to us about is is captain
plum said that they got word from
Stockdale and I'm going to misquote it
but I'm going to do my best it was just
because we're in a prison camp doesn't
mean we have to be on defense we're
going to be on offense in a prison camp
that's just a completely different
attitude it's choosing the attitude
we're not going to sit here and be
abused
and be put down we're going to step up
we're going to we're going to go on
offense and and they did they did hunger
strikes they passed word around they
wouldn't stand up when people under they
did these things and they went on
offense and that's what he's talking
about right here this last human freedom
to choose one's attitude in any given
set of circumstances we always have that
choice no matter what the circumstances
are that surround you you always have
that choice
back to the book and there are always
choices to make every day every hour
offered the opportunity to make a
decision a decision was determined
whether you would or would not submit to
those powers which threatened to rob you
of your very self your inner freedom
which determined whether or not you
would become the placing of circumstance
renouncing freedom and dignity to become
molded into the form of the typical
inmate
again there it is you can you're in a
concentration camp doomed doomed and yet
you can hang on to that last that last
bastion of freedom in your soul and not
let them win
and not let them own that back to the
book seeing from this point of view the
mental reactions of the inmates of a
concentration camp
must seem more to us than the mere
expression of certain physical and
sociological conditions even though
conditions such as lack of sleep
insufficient food and various mental
stresses may suggest that the inmates
were bound to react in certain ways in
the final analysis it becomes clear that
the sort of person the prisoner became
was the result of inner decision and not
the result of camp influences alone
think about that the sort of person the
prisoner became was the result of an
inner decision not the result of the
circumstance here and that doesn't
matter what kind of person you become
what matters the decisions that you make
unbelievable back to the book
fundamentally therefore any man can even
under such circumstances decide what
shall become of him mentally and
spiritually ok physically you can have
that one can't control that although -
all the time but mentally and
spiritually I get to decide what I'm
going to be he may retain his human
dignity even in a concentration camp
Dostoyevsky said once there's only one
thing that I dread not to be worthy of
my sufferings these words frequently
came to my mind after I
I'm acquainted with those murderers
whose behavior in camp who's suffering
and death bore witness to the fact that
the last inner freedom cannot be lost it
can be said that they were worthy of
their sufferings the way they bore their
suffering was a genuine inner
achievement it is this spiritual freedom
which cannot be taken away that makes
life meaningful and purposeful the way
in which a man accepts his fate and all
the suffering it entails the way in
which he takes up his cross gives him
ample opportunity even under the most
difficult circumstances to add a deeper
meaning to his life it may remain brave
dignified and unselfish or in the bitter
fight for self-preservation he may
forget his human dignity and become no
more than an animal here lies the chance
for a man either to make use of or to
forego the opportunities of attaining
the moral values that a difficult
situation may afford him
and this decides whether he is worthy of
his sufferings or not so think about
that when you get faced with this
ultimate challenge brutal challenge when
life is just about to crush you that's
when you have the biggest opportunity to
prove who you are you know speaking of
of unworthy topics but this is something
I when I was when I first got to see
where I was at SEAL team 1 I ran a
communications class and when I ran the
class we I was like super hard and sure
I know it comes as a big shocker yeah
but we would create tests test
test on all these different subjects you
know what radio what frequency you band
with what you know all these different
subjects and I would say the guys hey
you know tomorrow we got another test
another opportunity for you to prove
yourself and that's the way I looked at
it they didn't always look at it simply
but that's exactly exactly what he's
saying here when you have these brutal
circumstances that you face that's your
opportunity and if you think about all
heroic tales right
there's no heroic tales where the hero
doesn't face any challenges and as a
matter of fact the worst challenges he
faces the more of a hero he becomes yeah
if he rises to the occasion if he
doesn't rise the cajon guess what we
don't hear about right not a hero not a
hero yeah in fact let's say you're
considered a hero and then this big
chance to prove yourself comes about and
you fail or you don't step up you're
kind of like this big failure in a way
even though you've been a hero the whole
time yeah I would say that's true
although if you do something heroic
enough people are like good with it
right I think if they're significant yes
I think that's all it's kind of the same
thing yeah I mean the bottom line is you
face these challenges and you get
challenged tad to have this attitude of
you know basically good opportunity
opportunity to solve the problems yeah
like Oh big challenge cool opportunity
yeah yes like those guys who you know
they start a business the businesses
like grows and then it just massively
fails because some mistake or I don't
know something and somebody kind of I
don't know whatever and then they well
they reach rock bottom and they build
themselves back up and then me no it's
this massive success you know oh it's an
impressive story yeah you know that's
much better than hey I went to this
school
I graduated I worked this job I made a
bunch of money
yeah everyone goes on cool right cool
yeah oh really yeah they want to hear
the struggle they want to see that you
were challenged yep
back to the book everywhere man is
confronted with fate with the chance of
achieving of achieving something through
his own suffering think about that the
the the suffering that you're going
through is in a chance to achieve
something through your suffering
that's an incredible thought yeah that's
an incredible thought now this next part
is something that I get asked about on a
fairly regular basis back to the book
take the fate of the sick especially
those who are incurable I once read a
letter written by young invalid in which
he told a friend that he had just found
out he would not live for long that even
an operation would be of no help
he wrote further that he remembered a
film he had seen in which a man was
portrayed who waited for death and incur
Aegeus and dignified way the boy had a
thought it agree the boy had fought it a
great accomplishment to meet death so
well now he wrote fate was offering him
a similar chance yeah I mean there's
there's you know diseases terminal
diseases and that's it and then what do
you do
well I think you have to choose the best
possible attitude you can and again I've
never been in that situation obviously
but that statement seems to be the best
possible attitude to take again that's
that's when we see people doing
something heroic that's what we see and
you know it's funny some of those when
we were doing a lot of the Native
Americans on the podcast they all had
that attitude when you go to face death
hold your head high be afraid of it and
that's really it like you guys said it
easier sitting here in the you know
according to TV of course yeah easy for
me to sit here and say that hmm but
that's a hard one and you know the other
day all the Joe Rogan podcast
Everlast was on there yeah and Joe Rogan
he you know Everlast was saying hey you
know I'm not in good shape right now I
wish I could better shape I have for you
know that I think he's got a back injury
and he's got this and he's got a
daughter that's got some kind of illness
bad illness and Joe put on the good
video that you made and you know
Everlast when he got done
Everlast was like hey that's cool that's
inspirational but how does that help me
with my sick daughter yeah
what's good about that you know and I
wish I could have jumped through and and
talked to him because this much I will
say when you got a bad situation like
that I'm telling you right now it could
be worse absolutely a hundred percent
and the fact that he's talking about his
daughter how she's sick and how he has
to spend so much time with her to take
care of her whoa well that's what I'm
saying yeah
be thankful that you're in a position in
life where you can spend time with her
be thankful that she's in a condition
where she can spend time with you yeah
and it you know yours she's still here
if nothing else that's good if nothing
else and so what are you going to do I
mean your your your other option is to
say my daughter's sick this is horrible
I got cursed it's it's not fair and what
does that do for you where does that get
you it doesn't get you anywhere a matter
of fact it takes you backwards yeah so
you really truly do have to look at
these horrible situations I remember I
got a call back from from overseas that
a guy was a seal was really badly
wounded and and a couple my friends were
kind of distraught and I talked to one
of the guys overseas and I you know and
and a man I at this point you know lost
mark lost my key I don't think Ryan had
died yet but like I was familiar
with guys dying yeah and I talked to one
of the guys that was overseas and they
said hey you know this guy is really
really messed up and I'm like is he
gonna live and they're like yeah he's
stable can I go then don't worry about a
thing
be happy he's alive and it doesn't
matter if he's missing a leg or two legs
or whatever he's gonna be coming home
and he's gonna carry on with his life
and it's gonna be hard and it's gonna be
hell and it's gonna be a challenge but
guess what he's gonna be here yeah and
that you know again it's like man what's
the alternative the alternative is he's
dead
the alternative is we never talk to him
again that's the alternative yeah versus
he's gonna come back right and this guy
the guy that got wonder he wasn't like a
great friend of mine but I knew I was
talking to people that were very close
to him and so you know I had to make
sure I wasn't coming across like hey
it's no big deal I you know look he's
gonna be fine it wasn't like that but
look look what the alternative is you
know let's be thankful that he's alive
yeah and he's gonna come home and we
know he's going to carry on with his
life
yeah and that's what that's what's
important so it's really when you do
look at these situations when things are
going bad and then you say okay well
what good can come of that and then the
one step further is then what happens
when someone does die then what good
comes with that and and my thought is
always the same thing I'm thankful that
I got to know that person I'm thankful
that I got to understand their
personality I'm thankful that I got to
spend a day with them laughing and
having that memory that's what's good
what's good is I got to experience them
in my life and they got to experience
other people's in their lives and that's
what's good about it but just to say hey
you know my friend my family member is
dead this is horrible and I can't escape
from this wrong attitude and of course
you're going to go through that it's the
there's the whatever those things are
that you go through it's shock and then
denial and then
anger and then acceptance and all that
that's I get it and it's not going to be
easy but I'll tell you what will make it
easier is to look at the situation and
say what here is good you know and you
know one of the worst things is parents
will have young children that are
terminally ill it's awful it's awful and
the best you can think of is they hold
them while you can
yeah right again get what you can and
grow the memories that you can right now
because just to focus on the fact that
life isn't fair isn't going to help you
and guess what you're right life isn't
fair yeah life isn't fair
it's it's it's a random horrible thing
and if you want to focus on the
randomness and the horribleness of it
that's where you're going to end up yeah
but if you can focus on the good that
comes out of those situations try to it
again I haven't been through that I
haven't been through that thank God you
know not that level for sure but the
best I can do the best I can assess is
say man at least try and look at what
positive is coming out of this and and
and focus on that instead of focusing on
what is negative q it's going back to
what Frankel said it's choose what your
attitude is going to be yeah don't
become a victim of the randomness yeah
and that's so and that goes on like all
levels you know how even if like
something isn't horrible it's just kind
of junk you know all the way down to
just something that's pretty horrible oh
there's still a lot of good going on in
the situation but and just like are you
saying like your attitude or another way
to put it is what you're looking for to
internalise you know a lot of times then
it's natural and I've been there where
it's like everything just seems bad
even the smile like if something real
bad happens that you think is real bad
and then the same day or the next day or
whatever something small bad happens
it'll just add big-time to the badness
like nothing's going right kind of force
trying to attitude meanwhile all the
good things are going on all around
we're not the clear with all those
layers yeah so in a lot of times with
like real bad situations especially fish
with kids because that's like the
week you can ever feel really like your
kid like when my daughter had she had a
big staph infection in her linked note
so every negotiation hospital for week
and we're there that's like the most
weekend that that you'll feel and of
course there's way worse situations yeah
you know then that that's nothing
compared to situations I know that but
there are good things that a are still
going on in your situation your life
let's say B there's good situations that
can come of it and a lot of them a lot
of them is just our strength related you
know like if you let something beat you
down and you don't get the strength like
that's a loss you'll lose like you'll
while you're getting some kind of
conditioning from it in a way no matter
speaking yes so like if you have a
quote-unquote good attitude when you
emerge from the situation you will have
strength now if you don't you won't
you'll have weakness you'll be you know
gun-shy everything happens bad my life
sucks and you know you'll continue down
kind of that road so the good part like
if you said like I you said if you keep
that good attitude and when you make it
out you will have this among the other
good things that can come from it you
will have the strength yeah you're right
and I mean just look at captain plum and
look at Colonel reader there for those
guys to go through what they went
through and and maintain a positive
attitude and then they come out and you
talk to us and it's like yeah I don't
you can't think of more positive people
yeah in the world yeah you know I mean
not the whole world but you there just
have so much positivity because they've
been through something and they had to
maintain that attitude so you're right
when they come out it's like how I'm
gonna make and I think that's what
happens with a lot of times with guys
that have been to war is they come back
and they're like happy to see the Sun
Rise I know I am right I'm happy to see
the Sun Rise I'm happier than a lot of
people to see the Sun Rise I appreciate
that thing yeah and I think when people
go through some kind of devastating
disease in their family or themselves
same thing once they get through it
right they at least come out the other
side and they can appreciate it and yet
if they let it beat them down it's gonna
it's gonna everything is going to look
down if you're looking down you're going
to look down if you're
came up you're gonna look up yeah it's
got to be a it's hard I mean it's so
hard for people very hard yeah and again
I'm over here talking you know yeah for
sure both of us are yeah when I was on
Joe Rogan we started off talking about
Chris Cornell it killed himself we kind
of cursory kind of talked about
depression and neither water I mean I
definitely am NOT claiming claiming to
be any kind of expert at all about it
and I even said on there I was like look
I've never felt this way and I it's a
couple people hit me up on social media
like you know you should you should read
this or you should do this or and and
you know or you're not right I'm like no
I wasn't even trying to say anything
that I'm right I'm just tell I was
saying I don't actually even know yeah
and and so yeah I'm not you know
certainly an expert on how to overcome
you know horrible situations but I've
been in some pretty horrible situations
and this is what my thoughts tried to be
yeah and it's not always easy you know
at all yeah Jordan Peterson has some
good good um you know good content on
that where he basically in that gel he
says get yourself together we're in his
example one of the men was you know a
family member dies or whatever
get yourself together so you know what
are you going to do are you going to
wallow with the rest of the people so no
one can get a hold of anything in the
funerals a mess or whatever are you
gonna get yourself together grief for
sure game but get yourself together so
you can kind of lead and get the funeral
together and take care of the business
or whatever it's such a cold-blooded
thing to say right it's the complete and
that's what I think is hard about it is
you know think about this oh if someone
in your family died Mel's like I'll go
get yourself together right you know to
me like I who says that yeah but that's
probably the best thing I could possibly
say to you know I might need to say the
more tactful way three I made to say hey
echo man I feel for you hey man what we
need to do is breathe but we also need
to focus on moving for you know what I
mean is that kind of thing but the
reality is what am I really saying I'm
really saying hey get yourself together
you got to move on we got to move on we
got to move forward you got to move
forward in your life and that's like
such a hard thing to say to somebody
yeah but that's probably the right
attitude the cake is okay like this is
horrible and I need to keep it together
yeah yeah yeah man especially when
there's no majorly prevalent things that
are at risk at that moment as well like
you know like your situation at
situation I think uh
btf Tony was talking about this one it's
like you're in a firefight or something
like that and some gets hit you don't
just quit
no exit the firefight of you oh my gosh
my guys hit use it it's like okay he
said boom let's continue the firefight
but let's say there was no firefight
then the guy who gets hit it's it seems
like a harder thing to to just move on
in so what are you fighting means you
need to like you need to have a
firefight going on also that you like it
you can say okay I'm gonna deal with
this but I need to also think about the
rest of life yeah so hard and you know
again it's it's I you know what I'm
feeling like right now I got I get some
social media sometimes for someone will
say hey I'm not a vet but like a friend
of mine is going through problems and I
don't know how to talk to him because
I'm not a vet and that's kind of like
what I feel like right now like I
haven't been through those kind of
suffering so I'm throwing darts but I'm
throwing them based on what I know so
it's the best like you know yeah best I
could do right yeah you like you're at
risk with someone say hey you you simply
don't understand why the fact is there
right yeah and my statement that we yes
I don't understand you know it's like in
the in when I was talking to veterans
saying look people you feel like people
don't understand they don't and that's
okay and so definitely not sitting here
saying oh you know I know this is what
you do in a situation like that no I
don't know yeah I don't know what you do
when your family members suffer
something egregious like that like a
terminal disease or death I don't know
haven't been through it what I have been
through is losing guys in combat that I
have been through this is this is
darkness it's a different kind of
darkness but this is what I did yeah in
those situations and that's what I
would think would help you in these
other situations hard the question right
what do you what'd he do hearted we are
we are sitting here reading a book by a
guy that was in a concentration camp and
he's saying this thing to do you know so
that's that's another sort of
reinforcement of this thought pattern
yeah alright he talks a little bit about
the passage of time here in camp a small
unit of time a day for example filled
with hourly tortures and fatigue
appeared endless a larger time unit
perhaps a week seemed to pass very
quickly
my comrades agreed when I said that in
the camp a day lasted longer than a week
how paradoxical was our time experience
and that's something this actually
reminded me I was talking to our Sara
Armstrong and she and when I was
actually around the conversation when
Lafe was talking about he'd come out
here and seen all my kids my kids are
all grown up now basically he's there
for my littlest one but you know my
oldest daughter's graduating high school
in a couple of weeks and she's gonna go
to college and you know when Lafe met
her she was what was that twelve years
ago so she was you know life
no five six six something like that so
you know younger than when he came out
here you know he just come left his
apartment in New York City where he's
got his wife and kids now and you know
it's chaos and the little kids and
they're crying and screaming and
spilling stuff and throwing up milk and
pissing everywhere and it's just you
know it's that's what life is we're
there and you know he came out here and
saw how my kids were now grown up know
that time had gone by the way gone I get
it back and and he you know he talked
about it on the podcast just day and
make sure you appreciate those and Sarah
Armstrong you know said something along
the lines of the days are long but the
years are short yeah
that's a very true statement and you can
you can see that cure the same thing you
know all of a sudden this time is just
going by so quickly this is starting to
talk again back to the attitude we could
say that most men in a concentration
camp believe that the the real
opportunities of life had passed yet in
reality there was an opportunity and a
challenge one could make a victory of
those experiences turning life into an
inner triumph or one could ignore the
challenges and simply vegetate as did a
majority the prisoners saying the same
thing same topic
I know it's interesting I told you this
before we started this book you know is
a great book but I I kind of wanted to
talk about how bad concentration camps
were and I went and found some other
sources for that because Viktor Frankl
doesn't highlight it that much I mean
his ad I mean he was in Auschwitz for
crying out loud it doesn't get any worse
and you know can really give the impact
of how bad it was I went and found some
other sources that were a little bit a
little bit more directly written and a
little bit more horrifying to be lack of
a better work because in his accounts he
doesn't go into those some of those
graphic details which I feel like you
should know and you should understand
what before you talk about hey he's
keeping a good attitude but no no it's
not he's keeping a good attitude because
he was in a concentration camp but I
wasn't that bad no it was freaking hell
yeah and that's what he's dealing with
and in his mind you could make a triumph
or a victory out of those experiences
which is incredible attitude to have
yeah
going back to the book the prisoner who
had lost faith in the future his future
was doomed with his loss of belief in
the future he also lost his spiritual
hold he let himself decline and became
subject to mental and physical decay
usually this happened quite suddenly in
the form of a crisis the symptoms of
which were familiar to the experienced
camp inmate we all feared this moment
not for ourselves which would have been
pointless but for our friends usually it
began with the prisoner refusing one
morning to get dressed and wash or to go
out on the parade grounds no entreaties
no blows no threats had any effect he
just laid there hardly moving if this
crisis was brought about by an illness
he refused to be taken to the sickbay or
do anything to help himself he simply
gave up there he remained lying in his
own extra-extra de and nothing bothered
him anymore and that's similar to what
Colonel reader said how if you didn't
actively stay alive you would die
you couldn't just passively exist you
weren't going to make it if you want to
die all you had to do is stop trying
then you were going to die back to book
as we said before any attempt to restore
a man's inner strength in the camp had
to first succeed in showing him some
future goal in these words he who has a
why to live for can bear with almost any
how that could be the guiding motto for
all psychotherapeutic and psycho
hygienic efforts regarding prisoners
whenever there was an opportunity for it
one had to give them a why an aim for
their lives in order to strengthen them
to bear the terrible howl of their
existence woe to him who saw no more
sense in his life no aim no
purpose and therefore no point to
carrying on he was soon lost got to know
why you're doing what you're doing and
that's all there is to it
he who has a why to live for can bear
with almost any how
and obviously that translates right into
leadership perspective making sure
people understand why they're doing what
they're doing he just don't bark orders
at him but from an individual
perspective why are you doing this find
that and I actually I actually made a
post on social media the other day it
was something along the lines of finding
your inner Y or something like that and
I was I was uh you know mocking that
attitude right and I was saying you know
sometimes my inner voice is trying to
find out why I'm doing what I'm doing
I'm like my when I'm doing something
hard my inner voice doesn't allow to
talk be quiet I'm over here working you
know but there is obviously just like a
leadership perspective and from a
personal perspective why are you doing
what you're doing and that should be the
driving force yeah and if you don't have
that it's hard to overcome these
challenges
you can't just overcome challenges
because you know they're there
you need some greater reason yeah and
when that gets lost you get lost you I
don't know why I thought those I think
the when y-you were mocking that this is
my why and my interview was it wasn't it
wasn't now that I think about it wasn't
really the Y thing great yeah it was
more about the inner the inner inner
voice but ya know I definitely said why
on earth because keep I think people you
like it's like a lot of good expressions
or sayings or whatever or people just
all I like then they'll just start
throwing it out there and abusing it and
it dumbs it down and then now everyone's
saying it now it just sorta sounds
cheesy because no one's actually doing
it no one's actually understanding like
the real what what it really means you
know like the person who's like hey I'm
gonna lose weight and you know they've
basically spent their life
being their health or whatever then
they're like okay I'm gonna you know I'm
gonna get in shape and then they go on
this you know program they quit you know
but when they're doing good on the
program let's say the first or second
date I'll be like this is my why and
they'll show their I don't know their
their dog or something like that my why
where my kids or whatever you know but
then the next day they quit the program
like it's such a weak thing you're like
whoa whoa whoa you can't just do that
you know like that the whole thing my
why whatever that's way too powerful for
people to just be located my why and
then just yeah it should know just like
a little thing yeah just throw together
a 38 second inter Instagram post yeah
yeah are you why yeah that you need to
dig yeah you got to do that stuff so
that's why it's funny because like just
people just throw that out now not means
like nothing and it's almost like they
see it seems like it seems like it's
totally my interpretation on it but it
seems like they're saying it and
thinking that they sound so profound and
deep and new and inspirational you know
but everyone had an end to counter your
point I've had plenty of people that
have talked to me about you know I was
in bad shape I wasn't taking care of
myself I wasn't healthy and I had my
first kid and I said to myself I need to
I need to be there for my kid or or I
was doing bad at work and I don't really
care and I wasn't focused on that career
it wasn't focused on being squared away
and I was wasting all my money on dumb
stuff and I had my first kid yeah and
then I said I gotta you know this this
is me taking care of my kid and I need
to do a damn good job and that's exactly
the point right there is that it's a
real thing and if that's really your
your why conceptually now I'm saying the
expression you know like you for sure
there's a difference between G well
there's a big difference between the
contemplation that goes into I'm doing
this for my kid it's cool I'm gonna go
on Weight Watchers right it's like umm
no like think about this they thought
your relationship with your children and
where you're going to end up and now you
want to see them live and what guidance
you can give them as human beings and
the example that you're setting for them
and you've line all those things up then
maybe you can put down the donuts
and yeah that's right in other words you
gotta do it yeah actually you know so
yeah that's why it just sounds cheesy
cuz everyone doesn't says it this is a
great section going back to the book we
had to learn ourselves and furthermore
we had to teach the despairing men that
it did not really matter what we
expected from life but rather what life
expected from us we needed to stop
asking about the meaning of life and
instead to think of ourselves as those
who were being questioned by life daily
and hourly one answer must consist not
in talk and meditation but in right
action and right conduct life ultimately
means taking the responsibility to find
the right answer to its problems and to
fulfill the tasks which it constantly
sets for each individual again you're
turning you're flipping this idea around
not about what I want from life
it's what what is life want from me
and it's put me challenges and these
hurdles in front of me and I got to go
and jump over them and then I gotta
smash them and then I gotta set fire to
them and then I had to use that fire to
fuel the domination of everything that's
in my path is that kind of like hey
these weights aren't going to lift them
and it's the exact same thing it's the
exact same thing yeah and again going
back to this idea that war reveals human
nature and and this is dr. Frankel's way
of putting this exact same thing that I
say back to the book life in a
concentration camp tore open the human
soul and exposed its depths it is is it
surprising that in those depths we again
found only human qualities which in
their very nature or a mixture of good
and evil the rift dividing good from
which goes through all human beings
reaches into the lowest depths and
becomes apparent even on the bottom of
the abyss which is laid open by the
concentration camp so we've got this
ideal once again that there's a
dichotomy in people in people this
dichotomy that you're capable of doing
extreme good and you're capable of doing
extreme evil and we've seen it a bunch
we've seen it a bunch on this podcast do
you look at the me I massacre those guys
were normal guys that committed extreme
evil straight up evil normal guys that
were you know four days earlier probably
would have done something heroic to save
someone and here they are the other end
of the spectrum and I think that you
have to we have to face that not only
individually do you have that but then
obviously as a group you have that as a
group of human beings we have that
capability we've seen it over and over
again and if you want to know what that
good part is you got to know what that
darkness is too yeah the group thing is
interesting you know you know how you
always see it not always but you hear
sometimes about these riots on college
campuses whether it be after game
there's something like that but at a
glance you think dang is this college
filled full of just hooligans like if
this bit like you'd riot
you know but it's that it's like as an
individual or you know under
quote/unquote normal circumstances
they're just they're just normal people
you know guys girls whatever there's
normal people but then you put them in
this particular situation in some way
extreme or whatever you know it's a
spectrum but and they just act different
and the whole group dynamic to act
different the group dynamic is a
is it can be a very very scary thing
there's no doubt it can be a very very
scary thing and that's that's why you
know even when he's talking about and I
mentioned this on when I was on Joe
Rogan's last podcast but this the idea
of individual freedom and acting as an
individual is so important as to
structure your life around to say look
I'm not part of this group yeah hope is
not me
yeah this group is not me they don't
represent me
I represent me it took and I'm I have my
own individual choices and that's what
he's saying here the minute you give
away to the herd yeah that's when you
start going you know you no longer
control it yeah and when you give up
that control that's a scary scary thing
and that's when these evil things take
place yeah and then that but once again
that it's like it's easy to say now
because grouping yourself is actually a
survival mechanism true so you you know
it's not going to be just that you're
not going to naturally just be an
individual and act like an individual
and conduct yourself in all these
extreme situations as an individual not
just going to naturally do that true so
I guess it just helps to know these well
and that's your you're a hundred percent
right on both facets number one yes
grouping and fitting in is a survival
instinct that people have and that's why
trends happen and that's why nations
happen and that's why that's why groups
occur and people and politics yeah new
politics and everything right to get
into these groups and I mean it's weird
now because with the internet you can
have groups you can be part of these
groups yes really
yeah again whatever group you connect
with all these different people but it's
also important to make sure that you you
do remember they who you are an
individual then candidate that you don't
want to give up that last shred of human
will you know could decide what your
attitude is going to be yeah dang and
today you know in our luxurious society
if you can
consciously navigate your waist clear
that of falling into the group trap is
what it is the trap because your mother
is if you can do that successfully don't
fall for the tricks man like that's the
thing you get air we all get trip all
the way down to just something is is
seemingly benign as marketing just man
you'll just fall for way less tricks
you're like those tricks out there and
I'll do you know I don't put itself or
too many of them missing this is a wrap
this book is this book is not long it's
a very fast read and actually he goes
into sort of goes into the more of this
psychological the psychiatrist the
actual academic of it then I covered but
this is a fast read I mean it's only a
hundred and fifty pages or so and you
definitely get a raw look at human
nature but this closing I think is very
very powerful going back to the book a
human being is not one thing among
others things determine each other but
man is ultimately self determining what
becomes within the limits of endowment
and environment he has made out of
himself in the concentration camps for
example in this living laboratory and on
this testing ground
we watched and witnessed some of our
comrades behave like swine while others
behaved like Saints man has both
potentialities within himself which one
is actualized depends on decisions but
not on conditions our generation is
realistic for we have come to know man
as he really is after all man is that
being who invented
the gas chambers of Auschwitz however he
is also that being who entered those gas
chambers upright with the Lord's Prayer
or the shema yisrael
on his lips
and I think that's thought that man has
both potentialities within himself and
we've seen them over and over again
these grand expanded potentialities in
extreme display and we've talked about
these situations in the podcast over and
over again and the the Burma railway
that was built by the prisoners of war
and the prisoners of war were tortured
and killed by the Japanese in the
genocide in Rwanda and The Rape of
Nanking and we've also seen the other
potentiality and we've seen that over
and over again that that potentiality of
goodness and of sacrifice those men that
we've seen over and over again that lay
down their lives are for their brothers
and in doing so protect our freedom but
it's important to note that again that
whether the good or the evil is
actualized in the minds of men that is
not based on conditions but on decisions
and this doesn't only apply to good and
evil of course that's the that's the
most expansive thought that we can apply
this to but it also applies to
everything we choose to do or choose not
to do and everything we choose to become
or not to become it's us
it's our choice and we are responsible
we are responsible to be good instead of
evil to be strong instead of weak to
become what we want to become not what
we let ourselves become we own the
course and with every decision that we
make we actualize ourselves we become
what we choose swine or Saints
so when you make decisions every
decision think think about where that
decision leads and what that decision
will make you become and then
self-determine self-determined choose
what will make you a better person and
even in situations where you feel you
have no choice at all you still have one
last freedom and that is to choose your
own attitude in any given set of
circumstances
keep that choice keep that freedom that
hard choice
the disciplined choice and with the
discipline to make the right choice
maintain your freedom
I think that's all I've got for tonight
powerful book
yeah isn't it crazy how I can't help but
think of this like where how they talk
about the SS officers what are the Nazis
the guys there who are just savages
obviously but are they really savages as
people though or is it a circumstantial
thing I mean I know they're trained to
kind of regard this you know the Jews
are these groups of people as you know
beneath them and all this stuff but like
are these savages just as in because it
takes a savage to do some of this stuff
you know especially having a baby and
smash eNOS as the book said skull
against the wall like that's like
subhuman behavior you know well when he
goes home you know he has kids you know
is he like I don't care if these kid
alternately if their heads get the you
know I'm sure it's not like that injury
is just a normal person would just be
just as weak as all of us if your kid
stubs its toe and starts crying you know
yeah well we're going to explore I got
some books in the queue to explore the
other side of this and they're very
revealing about some of that but again
it's it's you're right that some of
these guys you know were we're normal
right some of these Nazis were normal
and they were doing their job and that's
one of the worst you know there's a
whole there's a whole argument on
whether that even is allowable like I
said if you're doing your job and and
I'll tell you what in the US military
yeah that doesn't that doesn't work
that's an excuse that we don't have you
can't say hey I got ordered to do this
thing that was against the law or
against ethical values doesn't matter
yeah I still can't do it
that's not an excuse and that came
directly from this attitude that nopsi
said hey I was just following orders
don't hey wasn't my father's fallen
orders no actually you can't you can't
pay it you're not allowed to say that
yeah so as far as the normality sure
they might have been no
normal when they went home but that
doesn't remove their guilt at all yeah
absolutely and you can't take a baby and
smash its head against the wall you
don't get a pass on that one whether you
order to do it or not there's certain
moral standards that exist and you can't
violate them and if you do you're guilty
it doesn't matter what else you did back
then who's kind of the you know the
authority on that like where the moral
was it like a global thing you know or
is it because obviously Hitler would
feel it would be like and whatever well
there's different societies that had
different viewpoints obviously in not
war yeah yeah hence the war the Nazis
and the Japanese both felt okay we can
do what we need to do to dominate yeah
and whether that's the Rape of Nanking
or whether that's the concentration
camps and the final solution both those
things were in their societies now there
was of course there was people inside
those societies I don't know I haven't I
haven't I don't know of any Japanese I'm
sure there were some Japanese that that
were against him and even when we read
The Rape of Nanking there was a Nazi in
Nanking remember that sheltered people
so there's an example here's a guy now
he didn't know what was going on with
the final solution back in Germany but
at least it doesn't appear that way but
yeah this is what makes morality and
ethical decision-making so challenging
yeah but there is in my opinion you know
a certain standard moral code that human
beings live by yeah and that is a
universal relatively in analysis now I
should actually say it's universal great
there's the way that I believe that
there's morals and standards that human
beings should live by yeah and when you
start stepping outside those bounds yeah
you're going on the wrong side yeah and
like anything men it's like obviously a
spectrum and then what you're talking
about that universal line that you cross
it's like actually when you really look
at the line it's like it's a universal
gray area of yeah and then you really
look closer but I think that the
circumstances don't really fall within
the confines of that gray area very
often so it's easy to be like that's
obviously
right that's obviously wrong well yeah
and everyone's in all these great areas
of emergent and it's like this big
debate and it depends on who you are
yeah I don't spend a lot of time in the
gray areas to be honest with you like in
my pattern I don't spend a lot of time
the graters right I spend time because
to me it is pretty obvious yeah like
when you're Isis and you're
systematically raping twelve-year-old
girls and boys you don't get to live
that that doesn't work yeah that's not
is that's not part of my deal over here
you you you die and when you take people
and you put them in cages and you burn
them to death right you don't get to do
that just like these Nazis that are
putting people in cut you don't get to
do that no yeah we go to war we fight
and we win that's the way it works yeah
now these gray areas that you're talking
about I don't mess around in those gray
areas yes III think there's too much
there's - there's turbulence in there
right and and a lot of times you look at
it from the outside and you don't it's
hard to tell what it is what it actually
is happening in there right I'll and
maybe that's not the best policy but I
won't escalate something personally
until I see it go outside the lines of
what I deem to be okay yeah you know
once you get outside those lines you're
done well thankfully you're you're you
know a little bit smart in a way where
you know whether you name these things
or not there's always a particular
standard that you go by you know so just
like like the difference between killing
someone and when someone says murder you
know murder is a is clearly defined you
know so if you murder someone like
killing someone is this broad thing you
kill them accidentally kill them
you kill them after planning there's a
million of the revenge and all you know
that's killing someone but murder is
defined you know so well somebody asked
me when I would attend Faris's second
time and someone asked me or something
along the lines of well who defines
these rules which is basically what you
just asked me and I think it actually
there is an answer to who defines these
rules in warfare it's the law of armed
conflict in Geneva Convention we follow
those laws right there they're very
clearly defined what you can and can't
do bullet that's it next question yeah
and and I mean unless you straight-up
disagree with the Geneva Convention you
know on because of your personal moral
code but it's
you have again a standard that you're
going by that will reduce the gray areas
by a lot and yes we're over there but
you operate in black and white when you
have standards and it won't always be
easy but you know it's like well let me
this this when we start getting the gray
area and you're sitting here saying I'm
all black and white and that's and I'm
actually saying that like hey once you
cross this line but guess what those
lines can get blurry - yeah it does I
heard about a guy that was on a
documentary who is he was he was a
Western journalist of some kind and I
gotta watch this documentary sure
someone will tell us what it is but
somebody else told me about it the
Western journalist he's embedded with
insurgents in Iraq and he's filming and
they're going out and attacking
coalition forces Dan yeah right
and I guess he was while he's doing it
you know he's trying to get his story
and do his job but then all of a sudden
they're attacking coalition forces right
now there's a gray area now let's say if
you want to take that example to the
extreme if we're in a firefight and I
see a guy with a camera who's wearing a
press badge following an insurgent right
I mean they going to work out good form
because it's not like I'm gonna say okay
well I you know he's clearly he's with
insurgents but what I'm saying is that's
that's one example of many that that you
could get into we're also another thing
that happened in Iraq a lot was people
change sides and they went from
supporting the terrorists to supporting
the coalition and then back again and
then back again so how do you how do you
balance those
yeah and I'll tell you how I balance
them was how can we achieve our mission
yeah and that sounds like like one of
those mission focus but it's true I look
at okay this guy you know a year ago was
being targeted by coalition forces for
being a bad guy now he has changed
course so what am I supposed to do still
prosecute him or is he gonna help us
achieve our mission of overall victory
guess what I'm gonna do I'm gonna cut
him some moral slack yeah because we're
gonna win so those are hard things -
that's exactly what I mean they'll see
the standard
the standard in your case became the
overall mission yes so you know you have
that say it's not like just some guy
floating down the road through life
being like I don't feel good about that
right there so I feel this way so I'm
going to do it's not that it's like
there's a standard there concrete
attached to it still gray areas going to
emerge but like I said it just reduces
that gray area that the bottom line is
this is why Peter ship is hard yes the
whole idea of leadership whether it's in
combat or whether it's in the business
world or whether it's part of a team or
whether it's part of a family or whether
it's in a concentration camp or whether
it's in a prisoner of war camp
leadership is hard there's gray areas
like when captain plum was saying hey he
got told an order you know make
communications with this guy at all
costs at all cost that means I'm gonna
get beaten and tortured and died by the
guards to get this guy this piece of
communication is he gonna follow that
guess what no he had to make a judgment
and say you know what though that
doesn't make sense that doesn't make
sense so this gray area that went
outside the bounds the gray area he said
nah I'll do my best
I understand that it's critical but I'm
gonna stay within me staying alive right
so that is what makes leadership hard is
you have to constantly make these
decisions where there's their gray area
and you're doing your best you're
assessing and that's that's again to me
it was always I love that I love that
about leadership
I loved weighing those decisions out and
I loved discussed them with my guys up
and down the chain of command and saying
hey here's where at me tell you exactly
where at yeah you know I'll use life I'd
be you know Lafe here's what's going on
this is the situation what do you think
yeah yeah well I think this okay that's
a good point but did you think about
that oh that's a good one you know I
mean we're gonna have those comes and I
had never had any problem opening my
mind up to these various opinions that
people have and I think as a leader
that's a huge piece of building trust up
and down the chain of command is when
you have an open mind to discuss things
with people and that also double
gravitational pull HECO charles helps
you build a relationship
helps you build a relationship and helps
you say oh you know what like it with
the men and I'm in there I'm talking
like hey Aiko we got a gray area here
yeah you know we got a customer that is
threatening to put us on Yelp but we
didn't do anything wrong
how do you think we should handle it
okay well you think we should just tell
them go ahead put it on Yelp we don't
care and we'll go to Yelp and we'll talk
to them that might be the good answer
but also it might be good to say bro
wait why are you so mad all right
customer
let's talk good hey we want to refund
you we want to take care of you because
our customers are important to us maybe
you'll give us a positive thing on you
you know I'm saying this all this gray
area yeah and if you have an open mind
to discuss things with your teeth team
up and down the chain of command you
know what you'll do is you you'll get in
that gray area you'll start to get
clarity you'll start to get clarity
you'll start to see better and you can
move through the gray area without being
without being so decisive that in a gray
area you don't know if it's black or
white right right so if you decide as
the leader I'm going black going black
then when the gray area clears up it was
white that you should have gone with
yeah you don't need to do that in many
cases you can say okay I'm a lean a
little bit towards the black because
that's what I'm feeling and almost done
you start moving there and you start
saying that no this is gonna be a white
decision yeah okay I can recover from
that I can move backwards and repair
what decision was made and the best way
to do that is say hey guys here's the
situation I thought that black was going
to be the right decision I started
leaning in that direction I was wrong
yeah now I see that white is the right
answer and we're going with white does
anyone have any questions about that
does everyone understand why I did that
oh you don't understand why let me
explain it to you here's what I thought
here's what I saw do you next time do
you want me to wit like contact you
secret that's what I'm talking about and
by the way when I'm doing that I'm
building relationships with my team
which is what I want to do I just was
talking to leaders the other day and I
told him and reiterated something I've
said over and over again the people that
did things for me and the teams that
were in the Army the Marine Corps in the
SEAL Teams in my platoon up and down the
chain of command doesn't matter 99.9% of
it wasn't because I
had some kind of rank of privileges over
them it was always because I had a good
relationship with people and when you
build that good relationship with people
that's what it's all about then they do
things for you and you know what you do
things for them - yeah it's not a
one-way street that I'm talking about
because you won't build any
relationships if you're building one-way
street right no one's going to be your
friend after you just take advantage of
them over and over again
like those people that call you only
when they need something from you right
now I actually don't have a problem with
that because I don't communicate with a
lot of people right I communicate on
social media with a bull with a bunch of
different people they'll get you there
but as far as if something like when one
of my buddies calls me up and says hey I
need this favor am i cool on it I
haven't talked to him for nine months
he's only calling me because he needs
something for me doesn't matter people
do that with me all the time and it's
cool now this isn't a big group of
people there's like six people in the
world and those same six people they
don't call to wish me happy birthday
don't call to tell me you know uh Merry
Christmas they call me up and say hey I
need this from you can you do it no
Mike's got it
no factor do you have a birthday
negative I have a manufacturing date so
buddy like I'm just trying to imagine
someone calling you to wish you have a
birthday I mean maybe like your wife
they were awkward when I got in the
civilian sector and people be like
when's your birthday I get whiteboy yeah
what are you talking about why are you
trying to get my personal information
attack you yeah what sign are you no you
don't know I think the was the other
funny thing about the birthday deal oh
that's like getting presents I'm not
good with presents yeah man but don't
get me any presents right because I
don't want what you got me yeah if I
want something I already haven't get it
yeah so what you got me isn't going to
be appreciated there's one gift that my
wife got me one time and I haven't been
thinking about why I haven't talked
about this particular whole situation
and that's there's a band called the
White Stripes
sir likes and the White Stripes Jack
White Meg white the white stripes are
awesome they're awesome band and there's
so
layers with the white stripes first of
all there's I'll tell you two layers
that I love about the white stripes
number one all their clothing guitars
drums keyboards everything that they
have on stage and everything that they
have on their record albums everything
that they have is either red black or
white on all the records since day one
that's number one number two they only
have three sounds in any other songs at
any one time
so those three sounds could be drums
vocals guitar they could be drums
keyboards vocals they could be keyboards
guitar vocals but they only have three
sounds at any one time vocals is one of
the sounds well thanks again and there's
only two and there's only two people in
the band
anyways the White Stripes is an awesome
band and my wife bought me tickets to go
see the White Stripes now I didn't even
think about I never pay attention to
when bands are playing or whatever
somehow I was I don't use this term very
often but I was overjoyed that she got
me tickets to the White Stripes I was so
stoked
and then Meg white had some issues and
they canceled the whole tour and they
never played again day well like a
couple weeks away from being in San
Diego where I was going to go to the
White Stripes so the question is it will
ultimately ultimate grand scheme things
was that a good gift to give chuckle
that was an awesome gift to give me so
look it was at the thought that counts
in this yes it was a beautiful city
Dodgers not meet you and I was and I
couldn't believe she thought of it yeah
cuz normally it's like oh you got me a
sweater from some store that I hate no
I'm really hard to shop for right I'm
really I find wanted something I have it
and I don't want that much so it's like
oh I want something I have it but this
once every 18 months
I want something and then I get it yeah
I'll get you like a new t-shirt or
something you wear now this t-shirt is
fine don't get me a new one
this one works good mm-hmm so yeah um
yeah it seems like a good to get off on
a tangent okay I feel like you went off
on the tangent
you know you know why because I was
listening to white strikes the other day
and I was thinking I never give the
white stripes too props that they
deserve
yeah and Jack white the prop said users
as a singer-songwriter plenty brother
and sister they're not allegedly alleged
that they were a husband-wife they got
divorced but they always claimed to be
brother sister my little sister Meg
white more lame no this is my big sister
that's right yes we always said saying
it's good man cool well the original
point was these crazy savage type people
maybe normal people other than their
crazy job yeah and what's and I'm but
I'm not saying so it's cool I don't say
that it is your your your accountable
for your actions yeah you're honest
about who you are yeah yeah and that's
something from any leadership position
you need to be aware of and when I say
in a leadership position
I mean you as a frontline trooper if you
as the frontline troopers getting told
to do something that you know is morally
ethically or legally wrong and you still
do it it's on you sure you can point the
finger and blame the higher-ups and the
higher-ups should be burned too if they
told you to do something that was wrong
but you need to be accountable for what
you did and that's all there is to it
yeah okay that's a rough tour and no one
wants to play that game the Nazis wanted
to play that game online
hey I was ordered to do this you can do
that can't say that don't get that
excuse you don't get the I was a good
person and I took care of my kids even
though I was shoving people into into a
gas chamber you don't get to play that
game no yeah man's too much rather
there's a small little documentary
online I don't I don't watch little
thing but it was about the executioner
in the Middle East somewhere you know
one of these countries where you know he
has this sword and it's his job you know
and he's a straight-up executioner yeah
that's it that's just a model a job that
he's like yeah yeah it wasn't old-school
no it's like on YouTube yeah like last
week yeah and there but it's like it's
funny because the whole feel of the
documentary was just real like oh yeah
this guy has a cool job and he's like
slicing people's heads off with great
precision and he's so good at his job
you know let's here's his family and
they're loving you know and they're you
know he's playing with his kids it's
like all this stuff's just weird man
anyway yeah if there's another culture a
lot of gray areas in that one - my man
indeed kind of anyway or not I feel like
we should go into the support yeah we
should go into the support support is
one of those good things very dynamic
supporting others supporting yourself
supporting others and yourself which is
a separate category of support to my
opinion
so there's yourself others and yourself
and others that's it
want to talk about on it we're talking
about all three categories support
yourself by way of supplementation and
we talk about supplementation all the
time but now you talk about
supplementation well you're the one who
turned it turn me on to it so actually
some of it
I took Shum tech before you talked
before pre podcast free podcast I was on
shroom tech I was an alpha brain Shoom
tech I got my shipment of alpha brain
pills the back end I had run out now it
only had the instant and so now like I
said what's nice about the Builder is
you got something come to become do the
podcast guess what
alpha brain pills and I might double up
on the alpha brain if I think I gotta
really get my favorite he did yeah but
it's good to have the the capsules yeah
well I dig you know what's cool about
the drink is it tastes good and I if you
get the sweet tooth it's going and you
want something sweet and you get the
peach the natural peach not the spicy
the spicy has a different situation
going on the peaches just straight up
like tasty like peach yeah peach peach I
enjoy just kind of situation yeah kind
of like that agree well I dig it the
pills I dig it and that's actually what
we had was the pills um I said we cuz me
and my brother we oh yeah awful brain
but when they came out with instant that
was better and it starts to become like
this little kind of ritual you know it
makes up your brain you know kind of
thing and it's instant I don't know
either way it doesn't matter um if I
haven't mentioned it already I think it
did these are supplements from on it on
it calm the way we talk about the
supplements but there's like workouts I
just bought a jump rope did you yeah see
so when I was younger I was good at
Chavez Ravine a joke jump rope - yeah
and then as I you know as I think kind
of when I don't maybe early twenties
kind of stopped so that's a long time
ago jump rope is awesome yeah so I'm you
know you know how like like riding a
bike eat and stay good at something a
little bit you're rusty you rusty yeah
definitely be rusty you can shred and
can go as long you know like that
conception shit's weird because it you
know how to jump rope yeah you know what
you were just back in the day of boxing
yeah boxers jumping up to three minutes
was like no factory yeah go jump ten
minute one
go get your jumper right out just get
out get out get out three minutes all
around you feel it yeah so yeah I bought
one of those and if so the interesting
thing about that is jump rope technology
has changed a little bit what is it made
of steel no well this I'm sure the steel
in there but it's like each handle has a
swivel the little imminent or ample but
like way more to it than before last
time it's like two wooden handles and
arm holes yeah for sure actual rope this
one is like a cord that survives all
this stuff I don't know anyway jump rope
the jumpers on there if you want
well the jump off yeah I was pretty good
too good man okay remember one like when
you jump rope and then when the you know
how like in this is like elementary
school and if you get tired or you
couldn't keep a rhythm they'd say hey
just just wave it from there furth you
know whether there's a name for that
move yeah what's it called when you to
turn to taro taro when you boom like it
like a matador isn't it called Matador
yeah goes by the time I can't get it or
whatever yeah I just get that rhythm
going oh yeah I don't know the name I
never had to do that because I was
expert level even in elementary school
but that's not that's going to be you if
in fact you want to step up so you can
get that on it not just if you watch if
you want kettle bells on there too
good kind well kettlebells are good
straight out they're all good and but I
it has those artistic ones yeah even
those add another layer but they have
the regular come the one I think they're
called the competition ones I very oak
oh hell no yeah oh yeah so yeah you get
the legend bells which is like what a
cyclops the werewolf
better look at them they're they're dope
you know primal bells which is like all
this you know primates and stuff yeah I
think I got the chimp two chimps and two
werewolves yeah see I have I have zombie
bells mine are just evil zombies how big
is it's not the one you know after Gary
look yeah that's looks like designer you
can you probably keep it inside - yeah
that's it you really do know the one
that I keep inside is not the ones in my
garage are for a bit long heavy work
this one is for oh I'm tired of writing
right now I'm gonna bang out some
snatches right
boom boom God a lot better now right
more of a write harder yeah there you go
but yeah anyway the point there is
there's very cool things on the website
on accom that and the supplements not to
mention this the fact is the supplements
are straight up the best ones straight
up because from the beginning and how's
this and I don't know if we already
mentioned this but I hear like Joe Rogan
talks about all the time how name job
yep I listen to Joe Rogan all the time
and says these things and I believe them
um if you get like I don't know shrink
tech yeah you're like Harry I didn't
feel it I got tapped out so you know I
expect more out of shroom tech I expect
this to make me tap out everybody
I don't like it send it back no you
don't even send it back you send them I
eat email saying hey I don't like this
stuff though to send your money back you
have to send it back that this is pretty
awesome yep
but don't be trying to be like you're
gonna give me my money back in the next
month after you're done with it order
some more and then do it again - I'm
gonna try - yeah you're gonna get
ostracized nonetheless um krill oil
that's the one you don't want to not
have krill oil even if you're like a
young guy in my opinion which I should
always been unfair and if you're not in
krill oil I think you are like a step
behind joint wise and it's a which puts
your behind in a lot of different ways a
lot of different ways yeah you did not
working out as hard I was working on as
hard struggling through various
activities in everyday life I told this
story whatever but I do it all the time
you know when you fill up water in the
big 5-gallon jugs yeah you know and read
do that at night when it's kind of cold
it's like bright you carry those things
from a thing to your car you don't want
to be worried about my knees or whatever
your back the trials you can do and you
gotta put it in next life yeah you don't
wait write your own book dude what about
like the truck that's kind of crazy
trials you've been through carrying
water on a cool night in Southern
California
oh very fresh like pure water by the way
yeah doesn't make it lighter though then
you still have to struggle but here's
the thing though there are micro Vikram
scrolls they're called micro struggles
is really what they are you know
standing in line actually the sending
line thing that's not a struggle that's
manufactured struggle so it's like an
exercise in discipline and embracing
struggle that's what it is it's not an
actual struggle bestowed upon your
heaped on your shoulders you know that
you have to bear in everyday life that's
not what's the standing in line anyway
if you need you talk about echoes
struggles right you can document these
various me looking for a specific why no
matter wine was there a tomato was you
like you got a tomato so I went yeah
okay there's our goal the wine struggle
and the groceries now we got the fill in
the water bottles there's four chapter
metal micro stroke and filling up the
water is not a struggle because I'm on
the krill oil
Oh omega-3 is frightening to my joints
straight into my joint for uptake high
percentage uptake anyway get on the car
oil I'm on the strombone now too
by the way for death for tendons the
tendon attaching to the bone strontium
separated about it does it I feel really
good about it actually more preventive
like because I lift
nonetheless strontium that's in strombel
that get doesn't if that doesn't hit
that like the limelight isn't on that
all the time it's all on calcium most of
the time calcium makes your bones strong
strontium just as much so get on the
strombone bone strength also alpha brain
obviously stream tech for high
performance go on the website
whatever you need they got it they even
got like try bland peanut butter nut
butter it's not peanut butter it's like
almond cashew and walnut don't know
anyways delish get on that one anyway hi
comm slash jackal if you want 10% off
pay full price uh that's all that's up
to you really
you don't say mmm I wouldn't recommend
it I don't even know if anyone would
recommend that it's also good way to
support if you're interested in the book
man's search for meaning
Victor Frankl what I have done is I put
on the website a page with all the books
all of them that Java is covered
everyone's launched a whole cover an
article this is the links think they'll
do that but nonetheless the books are
all on there all in order to by the way
so the most recent is going to be at the
top this one will be on there it is on
there if you want to support click on
there if you're gonna get the book click
through there directs you straight to
Amazon or if you're doing other shopping
hey man go ahead do the same thing click
on it we have a banner on the front page
too and then you can click on there yeah
and then you can use a shopping yeah if
you want sounds like a good plan even if
you buying duck tape also do you have a
link to your favorite duck tape on there
oh dang no no sometimes I say things
that are just so apparently really
unless I wonder yeah we will have a duck
tape link link for sure yeah just in
case
everyone needs duck tape and they
especially need it when they get down
list in the podcaster there
about the things that they're going to
be duct-taping together yeah so yeah
that's true you know why I mentioned
duct tape in the beginning and I didn't
really realize this because they didn't
think about it until a handful of people
asked me you know why why because you
watch MacGyver all the time actually I
still watch MacGyver obviously man no no
it's on a channel called clue CLO random
random channel yeah it's like a retro
channel kind of apparently diver man
well there's a new MacGyver by the way
new one with Elaine I don't think it's
as good as old one but it could be just
my but you know how you get attached to
your old shows it could be that but
MacGyver was dope back in the day so you
know whichever and I was just think duck
tea people people like to say well
paperclip write MacGyver with a baby he
never really had a paper clip
really he had duct tape that was the
thing I'm no sorry night TV all right
lay that's on you and I did it but I was
busy the America he had the Swiss Army
knife and the duct tape that was his
thing everything else he just found in
an environment is environment which
which change from episode to episode
nonetheless subscribe to the podcast on
iTunes stitcher google play all these
platforms that provide a podcast we're
on all of them boom subscribe whichever
one you use I mean if you use to I guess
write everything the two people use to
clap for and why why did I do that the
other day there's some reason I had to
go to a different platform so I have a
backup platform boom subscribe to both
yeah right is that kind of like YouTube
and Vimeo you know you guys love a gmail
account as well personal why that got us
committed a bad video about tell you
what well I don't know why but this
could be the reason like as YouTube okay
so the émile is kind of reflect
profession people who fancy themselves
as like film makers is my piece that
I've made an important it tends to be
that right YouTube is just like guys
Utah have a cute but overall yes exactly
right just throw my video it's YouTube
like I know the tube TV to you whatever
you are female is another name I guess I
could think about it but nonetheless
that's what it shook itself out to be
you know
so it's funny when people are like I'm
not on YouTube my Monday me an amalgam
artist
yeah you do you have to do anything to
be on Vimeo you just still submit same
exact thing
it's exactly like YouTube except for the
fact which now that I'm thinking about
it makes sense where if you upload a
video and you're like oh man in one of
these titles midway through the video i
spelt it wrong which happens to me
sometimes you can go back into your
account and replace the video even if
it's been up for a week you can say or
YouTube Vimeo YouTube you cannot yes a
new video yeah
so you gotta upload again and here's the
thing you can't upload the same file get
a really because YouTube's loop now you
got to re it it'll it has all these
little little information in the file
you'll be like hey that's a duplicate
file you can't do that no I only had
something to the advertising I don't
know nonetheless subscribe to Chaco
podcasts on youtube if you like that
channel we're trying to provide we call
providing value you know that's don't
say that
but I can sound cool that's another it
sounded cool when I first heard it but
it has another character and that's
another one of those things where it
sounded cool and then I one thought like
me or I think like everyone else
whatever and so everyone started using
it now it's like deeper abusing it I'm
over here just trying to provide value
and it just you know it starts to some
noise you just really don't do voices
other than excavation thanks taco
anyway subscribe to youtube we're trying
to provide some value there with the
excerpts and the various other clips
aside from the video versions podcast
your Memorial Day one was really good
like dad knows a powerful powerful
letter yeah
a bunch of other stuff um like Jocko has
a store it's called Jocko store if you
didn't already know chuckles store calm
what do we have on taco store we have
t-shirts if you guys realize Jocko also
has a podcast cheer called dr. chocolate
white tea come Jocko white tea yeah I
think I see a trend here yeah yeah the
trend is real for sure um nonetheless
the fact of originality and name-o not
mean things yeah so in a way like
because here there are layers in that
too and there is sophistication to that
even though it seems simple because
there I was being perfectly you are
being such a diva governor there's more
to jakka than just order that just
happens to be my name this - there's
more - that goes beyond this podcast
beyond the TV on whatever right okay so
just let's to start with that fact which
is complex in and of yourself then
you're like okay look this is what
roughly considered a company technically
maybe I get I guess or you had to if you
have to guy asked me today what do I do
like for a living and I was like I was
like almost dislike stuff yeah he goes
well what would you how would you what'd
he say he said well how would you
describe what you do I said stay busy
that's what I do
yeah okay fair enough yeah there you go
but technically cuz bar is dang I've
been heard that one in a long cool
Jaakko podcast.com that's an int it will
color the entity I don't know company
business it's a place where we have
forever
nonetheless oh you know what I'm gonna
go ahead and out on a limb and call it a
brand
no it's brandish whatever nonetheless if
you call okay bull Jaakko store that's
the name of the store yeah
well true so and to be honest with you
the reason that I called the podcast
choco podcast when I was on Tim Ferriss
podcast I said Jacque go hungry I and I
don't even know I don't know if I just
said I don't on the podcast or not but
he I think he says I'm like oh you know
we got agreed to
no like Jocko hungry-man does ago a new
podcast record Jocko podcast right that
was the initial Fox there's the layer
makes sense yeah and that's a but even
with naming the other word is I wanted
to be able to do whatever I wanted to do
and not care
yeah and that may be why I knew we're
going to talk about jujitsu and fighting
and music and hardcore and war and death
and I just wanted to not have any
limitations and the only way I could do
that because if you give the podcast a
name like you know the okay this podcast
yeah it looks like okay well then well
next thing you know we're talking about
war and or if you call it the war
podcast but you're talking about
business or if you don't talk about the
leadership podcast but you're talking
about jujitsu how do you get all those
things into one thing called the Jocko
podcast and I can do whatever I want
yeah there you go and if people are
looking for you they see you talk about
XYZ they're like oh you know I sure I
can look on that easy connection yeah
and it's simple which is like you know
simplicity there's a long way yeah you
know and that's kind of like a thing so
why are we talking about this I'm just
saying that's what's called Jacques
Cousteau yeah that's right so because it
is ignore people want to do other things
in their life decide to listen to our
outside cooking you're the one chiming
in I'm over here turns up like I said
notice that the other day when we had
Roger Hayden on and I gave you the
silent treatment and in when you looked
at me for affirmation while you were
giving the advertisers I didn't even nod
I just looked at you and you got you
actually got uncomfortable yeah you
actually got uncomfortable
you were like maybe you you the look on
your face like you'd look at me like I
was gonna give you a smile I know I just
look at you like hurry up and then you
got uncomfortable and I said oh you
start to feel it yeah you know versus
yeah that's like subtle gestures you
know nah man it's all good you know so
do that again right now you know so I
can talk about the store Joff ghosts or
chocolate or calm if you like t-shirts
now I'm not saying if you like t-shirts
in general I'm just saying if you want
to represent just clinicals freedom what
get after it
know the darkness
know the dark men that's a good one
um anyway go on the sir Joxer I come you
can see shirts if you like them go ahead
get one support that way that's a good
one got some rash guards on there one
new rash guard out already says get
after it on it discipline on one sleeve
freedom on the other sleeve Jocko
approved really good um I think it's
good I feel that the people who have
witnessed it
that pump is to see witnessed it like
there's some kind that we could live in
oh yeah yeah there's a lot you said you
in that's witnessed my rash guard that I
bestowed upon them by way a visual how
about people they're also how about
people that saw thought it was a pretty
cool that's cool is that's really I
thought it was cool and um so there it
is you gonna story look at it if you
think it's cool you want to get to
witness the glory of echo Charles's rash
guards you may go to Jocko store calm
and revel in the glory exactly right and
whatever else you want there's some good
stuff on there and we added this little
thing too if we're out and I'm generally
like I'm gonna restock you know we
should talk boom but I added this little
thing where it's like let's say size
medium or whatever is house it just as a
little button notify me both put your
email boom notifies you when it's back
in stock and again I'm trying to put
them back in stock ASAP boom boom boom
right now but you know give me a day or
two or whatever um well notify you boom
also psychological warfare if you didn't
know what that is it's an album with
track not music track word track sent it
like spoken word you know so basically
what it's for is you know it's not like
poetry so arguably not poetry but stock
on there talking talking to eat us to me
Chuck was talking to me that I actually
quite literally was talking yeah when
that was made exactly right so you know
you can have them talk to you would so
basically what it's for is he's not just
talking like everyday stuff so when you
have hard time waking up in the money or
you have our time because you're tired
and you want to skip the
Erica or you have a hard time because
it's lunchtime and I'm all hungry and
all they have is donuts here or whatever
but I would have to request name also
have you procrastinating or what do you
call it if you're pretty bad ending the
podcast maybe you could listen that one
right now Ariel I'm trying to explain
this thoroughly so this so we can all
have a really good understanding of what
its and its value that's that's it's
downloading over to me talking about
moments of weakness so you can get
through them yeah
next ask next comment yeah I guess let
me add this one more thing actually you
can even take it at moments of triumph
and strength and it will still work
you'll just want to do it more you know
yeah it's like drinking coffee when
you're not tired you know I mean yeah
double-bass
let that sink in anyway a lot like a lot
of a warfare on i-tunes FM music all
these musicals google play google fine I
think I think it's on everything cool
but yeah man do it right on alright also
you can get jock a white tee on Amazon
and when you order jock a white tee make
sure you also order more weights for
your barbells because your deadlift is
going to go up to approximately 8,000
pounds so you need to get that much
weights when you order it weigh the
warrior kid book it's been out for a
couple weeks now and thank you for
getting it also little warning that
someone put on Amazon in their review I
thought it was worth hearing and
thinking about parents be ready I bought
this book after listening to jock on the
Joe Rogan podcast where Jaco was the
guest great podcast bought the book
after learning Jaco has a book for kids
my son who isn't very motivated yet was
excited about the book when he started
reading the book a fire lit underneath
him he said to me dad I'm going to get
up tomorrow at 5 a.m.
will you get up with me in that moment I
realized that I was what I was going
what was going on and I couldn't let him
down
I enjoy my sleep like everyone else
but I was amazed that my son got excited
so I replied yes let's do it
got up at 5:00 a.m. and his alarm clock
must not have gone off but I turned on
his light in his bedroom and he got
right up he got his clothes and shoes on
and we went for a jog we've never done
this before
I had him do some sit-ups and push-ups
after and he gladly did couldn't quite
do push-ups if that's ok we'll get there
long story short this book only being a
few chapters and the only few chapters
in I was kind of surprised when I saw
that only few chapters did made the book
worth getting in this day and age of
electronics and iPads and tablets kids
don't seem to be as motivated to do
activities as when I was a kid I'm 39 so
i edified him after for making the
decision to get up at 5 a.m. on an on
school day and I told him that he can
apply that mentality to anything in life
boom way the warrior kid get it for your
kid be prepared to get yourself back in
the game also discipline equals freedom
Field Manual the instructional manual
for getting after it
feel free to preorder that one also
extreme ownership combat leadership
combat leadership and also combat
leadership that's what the book is about
how to apply the fundamental principles
of combat leadership to your business
and to your life also for a more
hands-on experience you can call a
chillon Front our leadership and
management consulting company myself
Lafe babban JP Danelle Dave Burke you
can contact us at in info at Esalen
front comm also the muster austin texas
july 13th and 14th at the Omni Barton
Creek Resort no fluff there's no fluff
just pragmatic information you can act
on immediately you can literally in a
break email your team and give
instructions that's going to move them
in the right direction in the austin
muster there's only 306 smaller venue
it's going to sell out so get online get
registered if you can't make it I want
to come to San Diego in September
September 14th and 15th for muster 0:04
will be there live and while you're
waiting for the muster if you need to
communicate with us you can find us on
the interwebs on twitter or on instagram
on that face ebola echo is at Echo
Charles and I am at Jocko willing and to
the military personnel out there holding
the line in places no one wants to be
doing things that no one else wants to
do thanks for keeping us free to police
law enforcement firefighters EMTs and
other first responders thanks for
keeping us safe and for everyone else
out there remember remember what human
beings are capable of suffering through
and remember that even in those
situations where everything seems to be
taken away when you seem to have no
choice at all in the world remember
remember that you can still choose how
you react to the things around you you
can still choose your attitude and you
can still choose to actualize the best
person that you can be in every aspect
of your life you can choose to get after
it so until next time this is echo and
Jocko out
you